kobe bryant's widow has won her lawsuit
accusing los angeles county of
negligence and invasion of privacy a
jury awarded vanessa bryant and another
plaintiff 31 million dollars in damages
they sued over gruesome photos taken at
the scene of the helicopter crash that
killed bryant's husband and daughter and
seven others carter evans is in los
angeles carter good morning to you this
trial ended pretty quickly
it didn't take too long for this jury to
come back they deliberated for only four
hours jamie before reaching a verdict
the l.a county sheriff's office and fire
department are going to have to split
responsibility for the payout since the
jury found both infringed on bryant's
constitutional rights
holding hands with daughter natalia
vanessa bryant kept quiet as she left
the courthouse after a jury awarded her
16 million dollars
she sued los angeles county after it was
revealed first responders had taken and
then shared graphic photos of the scene
where kobe daughter gianna and seven
others were killed in a helicopter crash
more than two years ago
coplana if chris chester whose wife and
daughter were among the crash victims
was awarded 15 million dollars his
attorney argued the jury should award 75
million dollars mostly for future
emotional distress the two families say
they live in constant fear the photos
will surface online
last week vanessa bryant delivered
emotional testimony saying she felt
blindsided devastated hurt and betrayed
in closing arguments the defense called
it a photos case with no photos county
officials say the images were scrubbed
and never made public an attorney for
l.a county said in a statement while we
disagree with the jury's findings as to
the county's liability we believe the
monetary award shows that jurors didn't
believe the evidence supported the
plaintiff's request of 75 million for
emotional distress
shortly after the verdict brian posted
this picture to instagram with the
caption all for you i love you justice
for kobe and gigi this was really a
wrenching trial cbs news legal
contributor jessica levinson says the
verdict should have a deterrent effect
for law enforcement they'll increase
their training to make sure that this
doesn't happen
and i think that they'll also increase
their penalties within the
agencies
in california it is now illegal for
first responders to take unauthorized
photos of deceased people at the scene
of an accident or a crime the verdict
was passed down as people across los
angeles were celebrating mama day to
commemorate bryant's incredible 20-year
career with the lakers
kobe would have turned 44 years old this
week jamie
oh it's all so sad carter thank you you
know i know people look at the dollar
amount here and go oh my gosh it's so
much money but as someone who's
well-versed in grief unfortunately it's
not bringing
kobe or her daughter back and i know
vanessa has said over and over again
through this trial that she lives in
fear she has constant panic attacks
thinking that these photos could get
released on social media and be spread
other places yeah privacy in someone's
darkest moments when they're mourning
should be expected it should never be a
worry i'm surprised it wasn't already
against the law for first responders to
take unauthorized photos i didn't know
you could just take any snap you wanted
while you're out on the job that seems a
little bit odd so glad that little hole
was closed absolutely yeah